[Music]
welcome back dr record where we talk
about whatever we want
we got sherry back hey this is water i
promise
it's vodka it's vodka it's the kikis
i love tequila tequila's my [ __ ] and uh
i love sake
i love soju and beer that's kind of like
my go-to i don't really so everything
that's pretty much uh light
i guess so yeah no i do you light weight
it's interesting i can't sometimes you
lightweight do you do mixed drinks or do
you just drink them straight
um yeah i'll do like a tequila something
you know um we got corvo right now it's
like the worst but we have you guys want
to get drunk
we have a bar me and bar actually don't
drink but this is for everybody else
let's take a shot all right let's go we
want a million views let's take a shot
he's hosting you guys so don't worry
he's gonna make drinks for you guys
anthony's such a sweetheart
anthony's taken but i think we have
something he's the best to be honest
with you it's fine
you're gonna jack off to him later he's
got cats with her too it's over
you have no shot wait what he's got cats
with her too
cats also y'all are like serious here
that's right
is that when you know it's real when
they're engaged oh i've seen no i've
seen it
she's stunning i love you i love you
this is all jokes we just want the views
i was like i can't stand for this [ __ ]
how dare you
how dare you he's engaged this match is
it just you and me or
well how many that's three we're going
yeah all three the classic degens
is jose cuervo the bad stuff yes um
i think this particular bottle in color
yes okay if you can get that size at
costco yes
that's true how come you you don't drink
nick you know what
last weekend i was peer pressured into
taking a shot of tequila yeah and i
usually don't drink and it was casa
amigos
oh i love cosmetics you know what that's
good i have no frame of reference of
alcohol but it was delicious it was
great that's george clooney's you have
no frame of rest
reference of alcohol you don't drink at
all i don't drink i don't know i don't
eat dinner that's why we're all friends
wait how come you don't drink
i just don't really like it but i'm
starting to kind of like it oh god
relapse relax relapse wait do you drink
no not really do you not really not at
all pal
not at all pal because we should all go
out we should all go out and dance and
stuff i want to dance
i mean not together just at the same
time it's the same place
i dance but i don't drink me right right
we don't have to drink
we should go out we want we want to make
it [ __ ] you yours is so tiny
no this is nick's we want to make sure
that nick's education comes at you know
like a reasonable rate right so this is
going to take like yeah this is going to
be ass to you
okay you might like it though but you
might like it that's good
i don't drink i know babe okay yeah
but you might like it oh my gosh all
right guys how did you know i don't
drink wait do we have enough
oh yeah yeah hey to sherry huh
honestly it's summer 2021 and some
making [ __ ] happen and feeling limitless
let's go and representing every [ __ ]
layer of who we are
representing every [ __ ] layer not
just a sherry
you realize that i make a speech like
that every single time my friends and i
drink do you need to tell you something
i'm always on a panel you know what
not as bad as you guys said it actually
wasn't actually
it wasn't that's because we were smart
enough to say those things
we mine [ __ ] you you guys [ __ ]
accepted me can i ask as you drink more
do the speeches get longer and longer
and more inspirational
yes yeah yes good at the end of the
[ __ ] end of the night i'm like
reciting harry potter goblet of fire
i want sherry to give a speech before we
go into battle like braveheart i would
love that that got me fired up
hey before we go dancing you can give us
the speech yes but will you want us to
seven feet tall
tonight tonight when you go into the
bronte club look at me gentlemen
look at me in the eye i'm looking eyes
up here
i'm looking you focus you don't give up
you don't back down you take
every bloody opportunity that's thrown
in your face
it's frown this is like what mel gibson
did before they fought the jews in that
movie
the passion of the crowd no brave heart
braveheart
yeah lord of the peaky [ __ ] blinders
that was nice see you're better than me
hey both of you guys actually pretty
good
period better than me mine was like a
mix of three countries i don't know it
was actually really good though
vietnamese in there wait imagine like
imagine like a vietnamese accent in game
of thrones
let's try it you mean game of thrones
game of thrones
game of thrones there was not one asian
in game of thrones asian
tribe or kingdom of some sort that's
what it was this right here the dragon
you know the dragon rah-rah dragons
oh played by that fan yo who the queen
of dragon man got that remix
i actually would love to see a period
piece like game of thrones but with
asians
it was they tried to do it it was like
the genghis khan [ __ ] no no that one did
they do
did they do kingdom with the zombies in
korea oh yeah but like how far back was
that though that was recent on that no
no no error-wise
oh arrow no that was like uh old school
very very gamer yeah we need something
historically accurate like game of
thrones for like the asians you know
what i mean like
dynasty i'm just saying there's like
dragons and white walkers
define historically accurate no you know
like what is
how do we even know what's real and fake
okay okay okay
fair enough dinosaurs asian dinosaurs
dinosaurs were asian
do you think korean dinosaur do you
think when genghis khan was doing his
thing that people were like we need more
representation
everyone's mongolian it's like oh
that's mongolian or were they just
worried about getting murdered by
everybody
all right this is getting very dark this
is getting ready don't get all realistic
enough oh
come on come on mongolia our history
teacher over here
white walkers yeah why walkers he's
always dancing do you see that
everything you do is choreography he's
actually just uh
juggling cool oh i want to see him just
trip and fall one time or anything not
hurt yourself
i did that here last time on the hindu
board but he flipped back up he's gonna
end up spinning on the ground a little
bit
and he falls gracefully was there a
moment
was does everyone have a moment where
they felt really uncool
oh god every day since i was born every
day of my life
as a child like a specific incident or
like oh god that was embarrassing oh my
goodness
it was halloween around halloween time
at my school
and i was dressed up in a full ninja
costume i get on the bus and not one
other kid is wearing a costume
i get all the way to school and i go
into my classroom thinking that
everyone's gonna be dressed up there
and i go in like this like ah and
there's there's nobody dressed up
you're the only one in a costume in an
asian outfit i was a day early i was
like
halloween halloween october
my mom tied the strings so tight that my
teacher had to help me untie them in the
back of the
club okay so your mom like was
sabotaging you
exactly she reads the schedule wrong she
read the schedule wrong they gave her
calendar
and she read it she goes into work as
well also in like a ninja outfit
by herself i like how this morning you
said happy saturday to me but it's
friday oh
[ __ ] and you did you remember that i did
hilarious dude it's pretty funny dude we
all know but i would have thought you
were cool though cause i'll be like oh
[ __ ] a ninja
yeah he's an actual ninja you should
just play it off and done some crazy
[ __ ] i don't know
well i think once the teacher started
untying him in the back of the class it
didn't work
so so you you just went into regular
clothes yeah well i had my wrinkles
underneath it because i'm just wearing
this
this like little black ninja costume
he's just in the corner like a reverse
corset you just
[ __ ] mom doing choreography
again no honestly though speaking of
like just elementary school i remember
having
this backpack that wasn't zipper fide
it was velcro and i was so
self-conscious
yes i was so self-conscious of this
thunder
that would [ __ ] be created when i
opened my backpack that i would spend
like
10 minutes in the back of the class just
slowly one
by one opening this backpack you had no
idea imagine how much attention you
would seek later on in life
right it's so funny and no one probably
gave a [ __ ] about no one gave a [ __ ]
everyone was also
self-conscious about their own [ __ ]
except for the one person that's next to
you like
open the [ __ ] bag if i was doing a
shitty biopic about you
you would be in the back with the velcro
and then somebody's like hey
whoa you i you got a lot of attention
over here
and then you're like i kind of liked it
and then what happened yeah and then
that starts it and then it turns into a
superhero movie where i'm velcro girl
i wasn't gonna go there but i like it
it's better it's also a ninja sidekick
yes
yeah i can't take the call
i can't get it off your teacher's
constantly with you it follows you
always
yeah and then the teacher becomes the
villain oh
the whole time that's good that's good i
always like that marvel
i always like that when you're watching
like the queen biopic and [ __ ] and
they're like they're like
nobody's ever gonna like a bam named
queen and it's just like oh jesus
honestly the conclusion is [ __ ] the
haters yeah exactly the conclusion is
and the fact that they didn't realize
that freddie mercury was gay
i mean like damn come on frame recruits
no so a lot of those like icons back
then
were really like uh gender bendy like
david bowie for example you know prince
you know it's like iconic what they were
that's why they were so it's like
airbenders but gender
right right there's fire there's water
there's earth
there's wind and there's gender yeah
and heart don't everybody forgets harp
come on
heartbenders that's just that's just
murderers
that's just a murderer that's captain
plan
come on you gotta remember heart that
fool was the most useless [ __ ] in the
whole thing
everyone had these dope [ __ ] and he goes
heart
brutal i mean i get the [ __ ] out of here
man nobody
nobody wanted to be hard yeah when did
it work was it like
when all their powers were combined what
about him by himself
does that does he like make a lion turn
away or i think i think it was like he
would
love the lion to death or some [ __ ] i
don't know i have to say i thought earth
sucked too
earth is a weird one this is a weird one
earth like uh whatever it is because
earth is like you just
are this thing but you don't have like a
thing you know yeah it's not like wind
you could blow someone away yeah that's
fire you can bring an actual air uh
airbag avatar last airbender where they
they actually bend earth and it's pretty
cool
yeah that's cool it is pretty cool could
earth dude he couldn't do [ __ ]
soil bro that's all it is today's video
is brought to you by
feels you know what's crazy so recently
i had like a
pretty big business meeting and
remember the feeling that we got when we
went to go audition
oh yeah and it's like because you know
like
this is about to be some life-changing
[ __ ] you're
and for some reason i felt like i was at
a job interview again or audition again
and it was like
oh [ __ ] i don't know if i'm gonna pitch
this project in the right way
so right before i'm like okay thank god
i got some fields put a couple of drops
right underneath my tongue
because i also didn't want to like drink
it with too much liquid because i know
the meeting is gonna be an hour long and
i don't wanna be like oh i gotta go pee
or anything
so that's what's cool about it you just
take a couple drops right underneath my
tongue
chilled me out i was able to go over my
notes reduce my anxiety and my stress
levels and the meeting went
really really good that's tight yes
there's a lot of people out there that
like to go to cbd uh to calm themselves
reduce some anxiety some stress and what
i like about fields is that they have a
customer hotline
you should have called them i'll be like
yo i'm about to have this crazy business
meeting yeah what do you think how do
you drive do i need two
drops or ten tell me the details the
good thing is
i've actually done feels quite a bit so
i only do two drops
and it makes me feel good relax so i
know my
intake so if you guys want to check it
out go to feels.com that's f e
a l s dot com off the record to get 50
off your first order which is a really
good deal plus free shipping don't
forget about that
feels.com off the record 50 off your
first order plus free shipping
feels can i confess something yeah i'm
about three episodes
from finishing it i never finished all
of it wait yeah
i know the first one yeah just in
general the entire series
i didn't finish it either i didn't even
make it to the legend of korra did you
watch cora or no i didn't
i didn't i didn't because i never i have
like three episodes left literally of
the avatar series
don't say that to dante is not as good
as uh
the the airbender i've never watched
well i hear korra has like
low-key a lesbian hinting oh and there
is lesbian feels in it
well to be honest everything has lesbian
feels in it yeah low key
true like what else everything i watch
when i see two women just like
be having a scene i'm normal scene i'm
like they could absolutely kiss right
now have you seen good girls
no oh i get that vibe from that show the
whole time i haven't
but i respect everyone on that show i
heard that like for
guys it's uh
common or easier for them to identify if
they are gay
versus girls because like i heard that
for guys like if they just get hard
watching another guy they know
immediately but for girls because
they're
so much more touchy and like friendship
straight girls
that they confuse that as like oh yeah
all girls do it
and then they realize oh [ __ ] i'm
actually gay and they don't have like a
boner meter that tells them
exactly we have like uh the boater
that's
important yeah i heard i heard that is
that true like i'm not gay
[ __ ] gay like i can't fight it like
yeah discovering yourself is that is it
like it's
right you get a crush on somebody and
you can't help it you just have a crush
on them i think it's like that right
right well yeah i i will say it has been
very
confusing in my 31 years because of
you know women naturally were flirty
were were
friendly like girls will literally just
do that yeah you know um and they don't
even know what they're doing in high
school those [ __ ]
leading us on goddammit being at my
friend
home and
and they're crying that person is crying
yeah yeah sometimes don't unzip for me
for no reason yeah
it's so complex right like just the
journey through my bisexuality really
quick um this is off the record so i
guess maybe you'll care
uh i remember these moments
i was uh with my mom's friend's daughter
and we were probably like nine
but we were just home alone for some
reason because you know asians like to
do that illegal home alone
thing it's my heartbreaking and i
remember my mom came home and
and me and the friend were like cuddling
on the couch
like literally she was like in my nook
because i was a power top at the age of
nine
um she was in my nook and my mom was
like you can't do that
like i remember her like freaking out
about it like you can't do that really
but it's just two kids like
but we were like straight up in a cuddle
position that maybe looked romantic or
something
and i actually remember and i don't know
if this is my memory like tricking me
i remember kissing her on the head like
this
yeah yeah no uh you are romantic it's
something like that
it's [ __ ] cute and as a nine-year-old
girl who was low-key queer and like
so then that happened right and then of
course just every single like
overnight bff that i had just eat [ __ ]
clearly no no no no eating
oh [ __ ] but like i clearly had a crush
on them even though it just felt like it
was like oh sleepovers
overnight bff they're like oh sherry
you're so funny and i'm like i want to
marry you
um i'm like oh that's such a good joke
i guess from what i heard is it sounds
like it's true right it's harder to
clearly know yeah only because it is
unfortunately society's [ __ ] up it is
more accepted for women
to have affection towards each other
platonically
versus men you know because everyone's
homophobic and
everyone sucks um but so so so then i
move on so
in these moments i'm still like huh like
i think these girls are cute but like i
still didn't think anything of it and
then of course i dated many men
and i was genuinely into those men and
then but in between i would still have
crutches on these girls so in high
school i remember my friend danika and i
we were um at her house and we were in
her bed
watching rent which is like super clear
and
uh her head's on my shoulder and i
literally i swear i didn't breathe the
entire movie i was just like so like
nervous and then and then you feel like
you're on a date yeah and then her mom
came in and i was just like
really nervous like oh we're not doing
anything like you know type of energy
yeah
so there were those moments and then
like um finally in 2010
uh i like this girl uh who was openly bi
i think she was 18 and i was 20. she was
just like so refreshing you know just
like
really herself and like so confident in
the fact that she was dating girls and
like
um and and i really had feelings for her
and i was like
whoa i was kind of like freaked out
about it to be honest i was like oh [ __ ]
like
this is the first time i actually had
feelings like before i was like oh what
is this what is this
blurry friendship flirty friday but this
was like i cannot stop thinking about
this woman
and i remember uh coming out to my best
friend christine and like in tears
because i was like
this is this is major this is a huge new
chapter in my life you know and like
um so after that essentially i just
was notoriously in love with straight
women
so after why do you want the forbidden
which is weird i don't know
and this is something i'm unpacking you
know like clearly there's
something about the emotional cul-de-sac
but
but i because after that it was like
three women in a row i was head over
heels for that was like unrequited love
um and then like so and to be honest
till this day
um i don't know so if you know that
they're gay or
or by you're like i want the straight
one it's no but i've also had crushes on
uh queer women as well
and then like you know we won't get into
like
relationships well just the point is the
surface of it all it's interesting i'm
like really like
i have fallen for so many straight women
um
yeah yeah you and i have that in common
if i'm directing this movie
you're on a date with a guy in a movie
theater and then a chick leans over real
quick and you see her cleavage and then
you look at the camera and
it goes nice
the credits play there's [ __ ] flames
yeah i'm very visual i'm a very visual
director no my movie would be called
portrait of a lady left on red
left on red left on red um thank you did
y'all see portrait of a lady on fire
i did not it's a period piece oh it's a
oh okay well in that case thank you for
laughing
um it's a period piece uh movie
that was huge last year about two queer
women
but it's like appear pieces a long time
ago type vibe two white women
we need more queer stories with
women of color please you could write it
and make it no here's the thing and i'll
talk about
it because it's off the record it's all
about me the show i'm on good trouble
okay
like i'm so [ __ ] proud of it and i'm
such a fan of it and literally like
these
new episodes coming out in july
like the storyline and and the
exploration of
of two queer asian women
name one other tv show right now that
portrays love between two
asian women only porno yeah
nothing and here i am doing that [ __ ] on
the [ __ ] tv screen and it means the
world
like it truly means the world i'm like
in that that one week when we were
filming that
and like these aren't two two girls who
like just make out at a bar there's
history there's layers to the
relationship and there's nuances
dynamics like
it's just the fact that like it's been
missing for so long and it's
overdue and i finally feel seen and i'm
the one doing it like it's just
i'm like what i want more we need more
here i am i'm always on a panel but you
all are engaged right here that's
awesome it takes a trouble you're super
excited and i'm like
you know just just you know there's
definitely girls in my dms whether
they're queer whether they're asian
whether they're just [ __ ] human
who really feel like this show is doing
so much and
it's just yeah good trouble y'all new
episodes july
14th so tune in to see some asian girls
kissing
that's how we got together it's such a
controversial thing because i feel like
i'm so light years ahead
of what's socially acceptable that to me
it blows my mind that this is something
so new
yeah and still i'm just kind of like
right
because two girls kissing what's the big
[ __ ] deal right
it's just loving a human being and i
think i can speak for everyone when i
say as long as they're both hot
exactly that's right steve i'm very hot
i turn it on when i need to babe you all
see my pictures i contour
i contour honey
you know what you're doing sherry
everything's pre-meditated yeah honey
uh but yeah truly it's it's just
more so you know just moving it forward
and like
showing these cultural specific yet
universal stories you know and like
normalizing it
um and also just representing this
authentic experience making everyone
human not just a porno character right
exactly do you feel like if you
if your mom had walked in the room and
she saw you on the girl and it wasn't a
big deal that it would have been easier
for you
sure of course yeah yeah yeah for sure
when you're at nine yeah because even
when i because she made it sexual
no it's just in general she was just
like the [ __ ] you cuddling your homie
for
the pretense was weird right so that you
think it's bad already and even when i
came out to my mom
like good trouble the show we've done 50
[ __ ] episodes and i'm
counting my blessings and this show when
i booked this character because the
character is lesbian
you know asian and she's not out to her
parents in the beginning of the season
and
so this is extremely relatable totally
and she aspires to be a comedian so like
it literally is my life oh that's
perfect um
so when i booked the role i thought to
myself like
this has the potential to be a role
model you know i i potentially
have a platform by portraying this
character
so that actually you know impacted me to
come out to my mom
because bisexuality my friends knew i
was out here living my best life but i
never actually had a conversation with
my mom
who is my rock my [ __ ] life you know
and like she and i are so close and
she's so proud of me
in all my uh career stuff and like we've
never had that conversation
because honestly let's be real like in
an immigrant household asian household
dating's not talked about let alone
sexuality
at the dinner table when you're growing
up so you know i finally have the
conversation with her and i'm like you
know this character that i'm playing
this show that i just booked
um she's a lesbian and my mom was like
oh okay
that's fine and i'm like well you know
like um i'm kind of one yeah i'm kind of
one yeah
essentially and it was just 45 minutes
of me just bawling and that's what
happens when you
come out of the closet you cry the most
because this weight that's lifted
i mean jesus christ you just your mom
you know and like
that the queer asian experience is just
so complex because there's so many
factors of like you know i was never
perfect i have a dui
i was like i spent seven years in
college my mom was very patient
um
you know was disappointing her left and
right and like i was never perfect but
yet we have this
expectation that we think like this
image that we think
our parents have of us that we don't
want to shatter you know and i'm the
only child i'm her only daughter i'm her
i'm her [ __ ] heart you know and like
it's just
you think you think you're not perfect
anymore or whatever you know even though
i'm not but like you think you're not
perfect if you just like tell her that
you're
queer blah blah blah all these you don't
have the chance to be yeah all these
things
right you know because my mom like as
much as she's supportive of my career
she still thinks you know
you know you need to as a woman you
should be a mother
no you should be a mother you should
start a family all that stuff of course
now she's like proud beyond belief
but she's still like telling me to
freeze my eggs you know um
but my point is that conversation was so
heavy and to be honest it's still a
conversation
you know i still have to steadily remind
her like hey you're proud of me
you're showing everyone pictures of me
and john m chu but like can you
be proud of all of me you know so i
recently had this um
pride shoot and i call her like we talk
like
criminally every day and uh i'm like oh
i just had a pride shoot and i'm like
mom do you know what pride is and she
was like no
i think she did she just probably didn't
understand in the moment i was like well
you know how may we just have like the
asian like celebration and stuff like
that
well june is like pride you know for the
lgbtq plus people the queer people
i'm like yeah just remind her mom i'm
bisexual and she's like okay
okay yeah you like both all right and
she was like
um okay you're doing all these shoots
like when are you gonna freeze your eggs
so it's back to her wanting to be a
grandma
um but then i was like well mom if i
freeze my eggs there's still another
thing i need you know we have the egg we
don't have the sperm and she was like
well there's places you can find that
yeah there's places you can get that she
just wants grandchildren no but truly
that was really groundbreaking for her
because before she would have
said things like you need a man yeah
right but that was actually really
a big moment for me like the fact that
she actually is is is now exploring the
unorthodox route she's like i just want
a baby in my life
go pop one out and plus i'm taking her
red carpets like come on let's [ __ ]
just live life you know but
um anyway the the evolution like truly
because i booked a trouble which is why
representation matters because i got
this opportunity
to play this character because this
person exists on tv
i am now liberated in my real life
spreading my wings
then influencing and inspiring others to
do the same
probably opening up a lot of
conversations nationwide too i'm gonna
make a manuscript on how to deal with
tyrannical
asian parents yeah you should you set
the bar so [ __ ] low
and give them no hope and then every
normal thing that you do
they will [ __ ] cry of happiness yeah
yeah
that's essentially what i did i went to
college just by going
just made her happy that's what i did
she's like oh my god you're not in jail
thank god and you went to college on
your own
holy [ __ ] brilliant yeah it's really
good
set the bar that really is what i did
[Music]
though
you